hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 16 the season finale titled the
first day of the rest of your life and
what did I say guys you cannot trust
people who live in trash and talk like
they're running out of room at the end
of a tweet I lay with a master okay
meanwhile elsewhere on Twitter Chandler
Riggs coral himself promised that this
season finale would be really good and
the complete opposite of last year's and
he wasn't joking unlike Meighan blue
balling us a year ago this season finale
gave us a real payoff really and
shootout involving a freaking tiger some
long-awaited closure on Glenn and
Abraham and Ezekiel's goofy LARPing
actually playing out perfectly in battle
and if you were watching closely there
were a ton of miserable details and
moments with hidden meanings so one last
time in season seven let's dig deep into
this episode and break it all down
starting with the opening images so this
episode opens with a tight close-up of
Sasha in a dark and closed space but
before we even see this opening image we
hear the music that she's listening to
on the iPod
[Music]
this is the 1973 RMB classic someday
we'll all be free by Donny Hathaway
the songwriter said that the lyrics
reflect the inner turmoil that Hathaway
was going through and that someday he
would be released from all the troubles
of a rapidly changing world and that's
exactly what Sacha is going through in
her own mind the world around her it's
changing too fast from the a
survivalists mindset where strong
individuals like her and Abraham got by
to a more complicated larger world where
politics is the name of the game and
Sasha hopes that some day she'll be free
from that complicated world and that day
is today and of course these images set
up a mystery that's revealed later on
but there are already a few clues first
you can hear a truck engine and tires
suggesting sasha is being transported
somewhere and yes Russia is clearly
running short on breath closing her eyes
and fading away these are literally her
dying breath and the way this episode
keeps coming back to this shot is a
similar structural device to last
season's finale which had its own
recurring point of view shots of another
prisoner being held by the saviors and
that episode was titled last day on
earth and it used that recurring imagery
to show what that character Glenn was
seen on his final day on earth
meanwhile this episode titled first day
of the rest of your life is doing a
similar thing with Sasha repeatedly
showing her in her final moments on the
first and only day of the rest of her
life and then after the credits Sasha
whispers words from a conversation with
Abraham which took place on the same day
of that last day on earth episode
wanker
hey darlin and yeah first I was like so
is this a dream or even heaven
in fact this reminded me of that family
dinner after life shot from the season
premiere like I expected Tyrese to walk
out from the kitchen with a plate of
cookies or something now it's clear
later that this isn't heaven it's just
the flashback scene - last season finale
a previously unseen conversation between
Sacha and Abraham's before they headed
off to their doom but I think this
episode definitely intended this seem to
feel like heaven with Sacha waking up
from a nightmare in the arms of her love
as if she's escaping the zombie
apocalypse into this warm afterlife and
I'll come back to this later so then
this episode jumped back a few hours to
Sasha back in the cell in the sanctuary
with negan reminding us of this
episode's title welcome to the first day
of the rest of your live show show now
negan uses a phrase to imply a reset for
Sasha this is her first day working with
the Savior's to get Rick back in life
but it turns out negan is wrong because
Sasha already made her decision to die
and this is just her first day at least
since Abraham died that her life will
have an impact also this big breakfast
that negan brings Sasha blueberry smiley
pancakes - seems like the final meals at
death row inmates order on the days of
their execution so this could be one of
the many details that foreshadowed
Sasha's death and real quick before I
move on I'm betting those pancakes were
made from Bisquick and if that's the
case it would be a pretty awesome
callback to Abraham
go on the Bisquick they try to make
pancakes
okay let's move on to this scene with
Dwight in the Alexandria prison cell
where Tara and Daryl are pretty ready to
end Dwight to avenge what's your name
again
oh right right Thank You Tara I'm sure
we all remembered who she was right but
notice the rest of now Rosita and the
gang used in order to trust white
because I don't trust him but I trust
Darryl ensure they all understand that
Darryl has spent the most time with
white and he's been crossed by them in
the past so he's most likely to know of
whites line here but it also feels like
the group trusts Darryl as the most
accurate judge of character in general
like a bomb sniffing dog it's also
interesting that Rosita doesn't trust
Rick's judgment and she's right not too
trusting Jadis turned out to be a
disaster for Rick like I don't think
Darryl ever would have agreed to that
and if you remember he was never present
when those scavenger deals went down
also real quick
maybe I'm just a Harry Potter nerd but
this reminded me of when they were
debating whether they could trust
Severus Snape a similar tortured
character with questionable loyalties
driven by love a lot like Dwight
Dumbledore trusts Snape therefore I do
okay moving on to the second check in
with Sasha and her flashback to Abraham
where she tells him this we didn't she
you you had it dream about me he died so
again this flashback is making it feel
like this is a sort of surreal afterlife
where sasha has life back in the real
world where abraham died was just a
nightmare that she just woke up from I
also like all this parallels what Bob
told Sasha on his deathbed back in
season 5 why are you smiling
I think I was Jamie and I think he
listened on there gave me energy so
again it's as if the Walking Dead is
suggesting that when you die you're
greeted by the smile of a loved one
and I've seen all kinds of glad to see
you right now
or maybe Sasha is just remembering what
Bob told her during his final moments
and then recycling it for her rebound
boo yes sorry Bob
now I was interested in this deal Sasha
mix with negan no this just mom okay
just one person has to die and I like
how later Sasha ultimately makes good on
her end of this bargain only one of her
people ends up dying Sasha and I guess a
few nameless Alexandrian too but really
who's counting notes alright moving on
to the hilltop with Maggie as she weighs
Robson's notice how she says this Meghan
finds out they're planning something
they're going to need help even with her
scavengers other side see Maggie already
knows that the scavengers can't be
solely relied on hinting toward their
inevitable betrayal
also when Enid takes Judith notice how
she returns the pocket watch that Maggie
gave her back in episode 5 that
originally belonged to Maggie's father
Hershel and he later handed it off to
Glen as a sign of its blessing so for
Maggie this watch is a token of the two
men that she lost and Enid handing it
Maggie is her way of compelling Maggie
into action to go help their friends
just like Glen would do so in a way Enid
have gone from jss to wwbd
and moving on to the kingdom errs
running into the shopping cart
roadblocks set up by Morgan to ambush
the Savior's similar to the one set up
by Richard in episode 13 but considering
how crucial Shiva's timing was later on
is take your really ten seventy seconds
to spare Morgan come on also Ezekiel
points out how Morgan is wearing
Benjamin's old armor which is why it
looks so small on them I don't see it
really protecting them for anything so
with this armor in these shopping carts
it seems like Morgan is paying tribute
to those two kingdoms that died back in
exit 13 and one other detail that I
liked in the scene was those red kingdom
banners the sigil of the kingdom
naturally is a tiger because now that
they're going to war there really is no
sense than hiding their secret weapon
anymore so now they're using Shiva as a
kind of fear tactic like you got an army
cool
we got a tiger and I know banners and
Sid
really only fit the Guild's fantasy
world and medieval chivalry it kind of
makes you wonder what the stills of the
other communities would be like the
sanctuary is already kind of using
Lucille as a brand but then Alexandria
could be Rick's axe the hilltop would
probably be a spear or maybe that
tractor Oceanside would be a fish
because you know they're near the ocean
and nothing else about them really
matters and then the scavengers I don't
know what a garbage can banana peel or
wimp in a stupid Walker pet thing that
they had or some like weird motto and
that's dumb broken language god I hate
these guys
and of course when we see the next
they're riding bicycles because I'm sure
they're like um hipsters are we saved
Earth cardio good but I gotta admit I
really enjoyed this awkward moment
between Jadis Michonne and Rick what
together I lay with a master okay you
should get back to work
Koral tweeted that Andrew Lincoln was on
the verge of breaking character while
shooting the scene and this might have
been a bit on the nose but the moving
van that they wire the explosives inside
it's called trust a move like a
not-so-subtle link that Rick shouldn't
trust the moves made by the scavenger
who will later of course sabotage his
explosives so they don't go off but to
be honest the red flags were all over
the place here like there were these
weird vibes between Michonne and the
female scavenger we win they also use
this weird bird call later on it's
probably a secret signal to each other
translating to let's be our trash
yourselves and turn on these people and
then there was this red umbrella
flag that the one guy carries like what
do you need that for come on and moving
on to Sasha and Abraham again where we
learn that Sasha's dream of Abraham's
death wasn't referring to his real-life
death but an actual dream taking place
before the apocalypse began Miranda
Beach it was before you got pulled under
you didn't come back
to find you but you were gone so this is
still kind of a metaphorical premonition
of future events because if you think
about it after Sascha lost Abraham she
definitely did go down this reckless
path to follow him until she herself was
also unable to breathe but it wouldn't
be Abraham without an awesome one-liner
I hate the beach
end of the day in a wetsuit it's like
the sand blasting your nutsack every
single step you take back to the car
this is honestly the best slide about
how much sand stuck since attack of the
clones I don't like sand it's coarse
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere yeah I prefer Abraham and
then when Eugene leads us outside
there's this exchange people doubt it is
because of the choices they make
so eugene is referring to the
Alexandrian digging their own grave by
not listening to negan but sasha is
clearly alluding to her own impending
suicide all right moving on when the
Savior's arrived to Alexandria negan
allows Eugene to try to talk down rich
essentially manipulating Eugene into
another intimidation tactic he's showing
Rick that his own people can be turned
against them which is kind of like an
ultimate cue also I didn't point this
out in past episodes but check out
Eugene's new clothes
the Chaya has gone full Johnny Cash
head-to-toe black even that megaphone is
flashed back in my breakdown of episode
11 I pointed out how Eugene's transition
as a character was modeled on another
iconic nerd from the AMC universe Walter
White from Breaking Bad and one of the
many cool subtle things that Breaking
Bad did was used characters wardrobes to
reflect their inner states with Walter
White dressing more in black as he began
to transform into full amoral Heisenberg
and season four and I think Walking Dead
is doing a similar thing with Eugene's
black clothes and real quick I like how
this shot of Eugene frames him against
that trust move truck not just reminding
us that Eugene is right beside this
truck rigged with explosives but the
logo seems to be ironically judging
Eugene someone Rick can no longer trust
but then after Rick and Rosita tried to
blow this former friend to Kingdom Come
and nothing happens
jatis and the scavengers surprised no
one by betraying Rick and then Leegin
appears and I got to say negan's whole
presentation here mirrors the governor's
return to the prison in season four
trying to use a prisoner to force Rick
to surrender but it ultimately ends in a
bloody shootout also I enjoy how negan
set up this reveal of Sasha kind of like
it's a magic act a large box set up
right on a stage vegan loves dramatic
effect and he's hoping that the
theatrics of a coffin will scare Rick
into thinking Sasha could easily die if
he doesn't play by his rules and this
kind of plays out similar to a magic act
with Rick demanding to see that the
lovely assistant inside the box is safe
and sound but before we see how exactly
that lovely assistant has transformed
the episode jumps back one more time
through Sasha's flashbacks where she and
Abraham reinforced an important theme
for this episode and the entire series
really
Maggie she's carrying the future day in
your house on the line for someone else
tear it to shreds form oh my that is
Levin and remember chronologically this
conversation occurs right before Abraham
and Sasha joined Rick's zum trip and
laughing the finale where they had this
sweet exchange what do you do I'm gonna
Meg just asking if you could do that
doing something as big as that that's
live and now we understand what led to
this breakthrough Abraham reminds Sasha
of the point of living in this hopeless
world and the point of bringing new life
into that world having someone to risk
your life for keeps you moving forward
this episode goes to great lengths to
give meaning to Abraham and Glenn's
shocking depths and the season premiere
also the season that followed which
often felt slow and unsatisfied and if
this episode didn't earn it for you or
if you've loved this season and didn't
need that kind of closure that's cool
but I appreciated these scene Attucks
moments and it takes a lot to make this
robot feel something then a few things
worth pointing out as Sasha goes into
the coffin one this iPod that Eugene
gives her is an older iPod looks like a
second generation which came out in 2002
and that can stuff with the continuities
our walking dead timeline
according to fear The Walking Dead the
zombie apocalypse begins sometime around
2012 but in the comics
Robert Kirkman established it as October
2003 so this iPod could set this show in
either timeline also right before Sasha
goes in she says this when I go to sleep
I feel like this is Sasha Sol talking
here like she's experienced so much
grief she just wants to let it go now
and somehow everyone just keeps missing
these hints from Sasha you guys would
make terrible suicide hotline operators
and said negan says this as he closes
the lid on it
[Music]
you are something else and I love how
that later fits with negan opening the
coffin when Sasha has literally turned
into something else so by taking the
suicide pill Sasha is removing herself
as leverage so that negan will have
fewer cards to play against Rick but
also as we've seen time and time again
on the show Sasha knows a little walker
induced chaos is great for levelling the
playing field between opposing sides
also I love the way that this show
adapted the Holly storylines in the
comics which plays up similarly with
negan cruelly returning the Walker eyes
Holly back to Alexandria but instead of
Meighan intentionally doing it all as a
trick against Rick's people Sasha
controls her own destiny and turns
herself into a weapon against negan
meanwhile sausage distraction gives Carl
enough time to exploit the situation
Coen John wick on all these scavengers
making Carl the one to fire the first
shots and it's all-out war and in the
skirmish that follows one people that
you might have missed the Savior who
pulled Sasha off negan and gets his face
bitten off is Roy
he was the it's vegetables not veggies
[ __ ] from the hilltop in episode 14
so Sasha did enid one last solid next
the Savior's and scavengers seemed to
get control the situation and notice
this short negotiation between negan and
Jada's Dale is for 12 yes Jim
they were a resource Wow
and this is interesting for both
characters in the past with Rick jatis
was a stubborn Hagler but now she knows
that negan is in the more powerful
bargaining position so she backs down
meanwhile recently negan was more
flexible in bargaining allowing Sasha to
talk him down from three executions to
one earlier but now after he realized
Sasha tricked him he is in no mood to
bargain then negan takes us back to the
season premiere again threatening Carl
and promising to take Rick's hands which
remember was something negan hinted at
in that whole episode but remember that
episode was all about the look in Rick's
eyes then he expressed a look of fear in
shock and submission but now his eyes
only show defiance and a bit of insanity
this season began by breaking Rick
leaving him weak and unfocused
but episode by episode it rebuilt him
into the bold madman he is in his finest
moment I'm going to kill you already and
that is when the tides of this whole
battle turn in Tiger form
luckily for Rick and Carl Shiva somehow
nodes only to attack Savior's Chandler
Riggs tweeted that they shot this by
having a guy in the blue suit jumping
from a trampoline on the Savior that guy
has the best job like I loved his work
as a magically bright carnival deer and
Ezekiel charge and war cry is equally
epic
[Music]
complicated on this day and I gotta say
after 16 episodes of various moving
parts gradually coming together it's
pretty satisfying to see all of these
characters in one place and one time
killing each other and it might have
seemed that Rick's allies came out of
nowhere at just the right second but in
the moments leading up to this actually
included a bit of gunfire in the
background suggesting that the battle
was still going on as the backup arrived
and one detail that I noticed during the
saddle is even while he's shooting negan
never drops Lucile like holding that bad
even screws up his aim and I think this
shows that negan's ego and pride
represented in Lucile are more important
to him than winning a smaller battle
like if his men see him genuinely scared
and panicked
all is lost for him in fact I think
that's also why he flips them off as he
retreats risking getting that finger
shot off even in defeat negan must
remain negan and after Rick and Carl
reunite with Michonne negan retreats to
the sanctuary and notice how they give
us this clear shot of Rosita the bullet
lodged in Lucile that bullet will
forever haunt negan as a symbol of
defiance from the people of Alexandria
and then I like negan's declaration of
war with a savior army which is adapted
straight from the comic we are going to
war and that brings us to these
emotional closing images with these
shots of Gabriel presiding over Sasha's
funeral and all the communities coming
together there's also a quick shot of
Daryl finding a carved soldier with the
word didn't know written on it that is
from Dwight remember Daryl has seen
carvings of the past and Dwight is
communicating to them that he didn't
know that the scavengers had to deal
with negan
we'll see if Daryl Anza buying that and
over all of this we hear maggie
explained to Rick why she thinks sasha
took her own life and how it connects to
the somatic through line of the whole
series that the point of living in a
terrible world is to love people enough
to put yourself at risk for them because
Glenn chose to be there for you
that day long time ago
that was the decision who changed
everything and that is why the final
shot of this episode and of this season
is Glenn's pocket watch Maggie is
connecting Sasha's death and all the
other struggles and sacrifices to Glenn
selflessness in the very first episode
of The Walking Dead when he saved Rick
from the tank in Atlanta and you want to
hang and now that they've learned the
right lessons from losing their loved
ones Rick
Maggie and the others have moved on from
feeling like it was their last day on
earth to feeling like it's the first day
of the rest of their life okay that was
all the cool stuff I noticed in this
season finale and really it has been a
pleasure breaking down and the Hooper
analyzing all of the episodes of Walking
Dead Season seven and if you haven't
already make sure to go back and watch
all of those other breakdowns there's a
lot of interesting details and theories
also a few bogus predictions and
far-fetched religious metaphors but hey
that's part of the fun of course I'll be
back at some point soon with my
predictions for season eight and
breakdowns of any season eight trailers
we get between now and the fall and let
me know what you think in the comments
what you thought about this finale and
all of Walking Dead Season seven like
did it earn those shocking deaths from
the beginning of the season do you like
all these new groups in the show now and
you enjoy just the general direction the
show is gone it don't know if I want to
know what you think and thanks for
watching and if you liked this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars we cover lots of stuff besides
Walking Dead like Star Wars Marvel and
DC stuff Game of Thrones also shows like
stranger things in West's world so while
you wait for Walking Dead to come back
catch up on some of these other shows
and broaden that reference space also
please share this video and if you
really like new rock stars you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current patrons you
guys are awesome especially you math you
solve us you can hit me up on Twitter a
TA box with any thoughts you have on The
Walking Dead or follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos all right thanks for watching
bye
you